Elizabeth Warren Gaines in the polls
Democrats struggle with their own
radicalism and president from safe ganna
Stan Policy collapses into chaos I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
there's nothing like reemerging from a
beautiful weekend to come back into a
studio where it smells like something
tied but the thing that died it turns
out in the studio at least was not Joe
Biden's poll numbers it was actually
something like it actually smells like
something died we'll get into Joe
Biden's poll numbers not the dead thing
that is in this in just one second but
first you may have been noticing that
the price of gold is rising why is the
price of gold rising well because s
geopolitical uncertainty takes a toll on
the markets people are rushing for safe
havens and bonds and in gold okay the
fact is that geopolitical tensions are
rising you can just read the news or
listen to the show one consequence has
been a five-year high in gold prices
recently Iran announced it will break
the uranium stockpile limit they agreed
to under the nuclear deal that is not a
coincidence that gold prices have been
rising China of course our trade war
with China is having a toll on the
economy and this is also causing gold to
rise well the fact is that if you are
looking to diversify into gold there's
only one choice that you should be using
and that is the folks over at Birch
coral I know the folks over at Birch
gold I've been talking about them for
years I trust them gold is a hedge
against inflation a hedge against
uncertainty and instability my savings
plan is diversified and yours should be
too I'm not saying take all your money
and throw it into precious metals I'm
saying at least part of your savings
plan should be in precious metals
because it helps protect you against the
vicissitudes of the market Birch gold
group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews
and a plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
right now get a free information kit on
physical precious metals see if
diversifying into gold and silver makes
sense for you this comprehensive 16 page
kit reveals how gold and silver can
protect your savings they can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of risky
stocks and bonds into a precious metals
IRA if that's something you are
interested in to get your no cost no
obligation kit text Ben - 47 47 47 again
text Ben my name - 47 47 47 okay so we
begin this week which is a big debate
week right because later this week is
the first debate in which Elizabeth
Warren and Joe Biden will share a stage
Bernie Sanders will be there - in all
likelihood this turns into a gang attack
on Joe Biden by Bernie Sanders and by
Elizabeth Warren
by camellias and by Cory Booker and
that's because the dynamics of the race
have shifted somewhat right now if you
are Camille Harris or Cory Booker while
you're figuring is that Elizabeth Warren
looks like she is taking a huge chunk of
Joe Biden's white support and if Joe
Biden should collapse is the black
support that Joe Biden currently has is
that is that support going to shift over
to Elizabeth Warren or is it more likely
that shifts over to somebody like a
Carmel Harris or to somebody like a Cory
Booker which is why they're still in the
race meanwhile Bernie Sanders is still
clinging to the hope that he is the
great progressive alternative to Joe
Biden not Elizabeth Warren and that hope
is not completely unsupportable the fact
is that there are several polls that
show that Bernie Sanders on a national
level al polls Elizabeth Warren but
Elizabeth Warren is doing really well in
a lot of these early states and it's
still extremely early and Joe Biden
continues to gaff and gaff and gaff and
yeah he's an extraordinarily weak
frontrunner as I have been saying for
months Joe Biden's best day would be his
first day and that has been obviously
true over the weekend and Joe Biden
stumbled s'mores in Manchester New
Hampshire and he continued to gaffe -
for years I believe history will look
back in this presidency as an aberrant
moment in time but if Donal hump the
Donald Trump is reelected Freudian slip
the Donald Trump is reelected he will
forever and fundamentally alter the
character of this nation and the home
Trump Donald Trump does pose an extra
strength to this the it's not
hypothetical his threat to this nation
men Joe Biden a lot of scrambled eggs up
there my goodness and he posed an extra
trick he's gonna be bad he's gonna be
bad guys Tim Ryan was a fellow
presidential candidate he's going
nowhere but his statements about Joe
Biden's mental state yeah this is this
is obviously true here's Tim Ryan
explaining at Joe Biden's mental state
is a bit of an issue here guys
I mean he went on colbert to address
this very issue it's not like I said
something that a lot of people aren't
thinking or he wouldn't have went on
colbert to talk about it so this is an
issue we have to be honest with each
other there's so much at stake in this
election we can't just put somebody up
there who can't beat Donald Trump
whether it's on the issues or on the
issues of energy or lack of clarity like
we've got to be very clear and I believe
that I'm that person I wouldn't be
running and so people can support my
campaign and go to Tim Ryan for America
nobody's doing that but everybody is
acknowledging that Joe Biden is
stumbling and bumbling and bumbling and
stumbling chris burrman style but he's
not gonna make the endzone he's gonna be
knocked out of play probably by the time
we hit the 30-yard line here because the
fact is that Joe Biden has no momentum
none all it takes right now is a solid
love tap and Joe from Elizabeth Warren
and Joe Biden has a serious serious
problem on his hands and Elizabeth
Warren may not deliver it what what her
made her smart strategy here made it be
complete completely inoffensive let
somebody else slap at Biden let him
continue to recede back to the field
she's just quietly gaining she doesn't
have to land a knockout blow on him in
fact I think that will be her strategy a
little bit later this week I think that
Elizabeth Warren is banking on the fact
that the media love Elizabeth Warren for
months we've heard nothing but that
Elizabeth Warren has a plan for
everything now her plans are bad her
plans don't make any sense but they keep
saying it why because you have to
understand then when you're a member of
the coastal media when you are writing
for the New York Times The Washington
Post of the Los Angeles Times you are a
member of a particular elite
this elite usually means you went to a
good university it means that you've
been hanging out with people who think
like you for a long time and the biggest
thing is that you don't want to be seen
by all the people who surround you as
unintelligent the the coin of the realm
in coastal elite circles is not that
you're the most moral person in the room
not that you're the best person not that
you give the most charity not the you
attend church the most the coin of the
realm is that you're the smartest that's
the thing that matters more than
anything else my friends and as Prager
is constantly saying that you know when
it comes to parenting what parents
should focus on is producing good
children not kids who went to an Ivy
League school but very often that that
sense of values is reversed when it
comes to assessment of merit and in the
media so in the media anything that
makes people feel intelligent makes them
really excited Elizabeth Warren makes
them feel intelligent she's a harvard
law professor she's obviously articulate
she's written books she's read books and
this makes them feel super good about
themselves they love Elizabeth Warren
and that says something about you can to
understand when you are voting on the
Left I mean it's true on the right also
but I think it's more true on the left
at this point and the way you vote is
seen as a moral imprimatur on you not on
the candidate it's not that you're
granting your moral imports of
imprimatur to the candidate it's that
your support of the candidate says
something about you so if you're a
Bernie Sanders supporter what that says
about you to everyone else is why people
put bumper stickers on their car what it
says to everyone else is that you are
passionate about the issues they are
passionate about inequality doesn't say
anything about your intelligence it says
that you are passionate and if you're a
supporter of Kamala Harris it means that
you're someone who believes in criminal
justice reform and racial equity and if
you're somebody who supports Joe Biden
it says that you're sort of a reasonable
elder statesman in the party which is
why you're not seeing a lot of bumper
stickers because who wants a bumper
sticker that says I'm a reasonable elder
statesman person right that's that's not
something Elizabeth Warren you stick
that on your on your bumper sticker and
you feel progressive but not only do you
feel progressive you get sort of the
quality of Bernie Sanders but you also
get to say and I'm so smart too because
she has so many plans for the media that
describes them to a tee so they've been
praising Elizabeth Warren non-stop for
months for months my first they tried to
run interference for her after her whole
ridiculous I'm not a Native American but
I am a Native American gaffe they tried
to pretend that her DNA tests actually
exonerated her on that particular
claim and then when that failed they
shifted gears and suddenly it was
doesn't she have plans guys I mean she
has so many plans well one of elizabeth
warren's big plans that the media have
paid very little attention to I mean
they've run a couple of fact checks but
then they've ignored it and so she keeps
continuing to claim it is that all of
her giant plans will be paid for by an
enormous wealth tax and this is it this
is Elizabeth Warren over the weekend at
the New Hampshire Democratic Party
convention explaining that all she's
gonna do is tax people who have assets
more than fifty million dollars two or
three percent she's gonna take all their
money from them at that rate because
again remember that's every single year
she's gonna take two or three percent of
their net wealth and then she is going
to use that for a variety of government
programs and oh what a plan oh what a
plan Elizabeth Warren you're first fifty
million dollars free and clear but
you're 50 million thin first dollar you
got to pitch in two cents and two cents
for every dollar after that and what can
we do with two cents we can do universal
child care for every baby in this
country agency ratified
we can make technical school community
college and four-year college free for
everyone who wants to education we can
do all of that and cancelled student
loan debt for 95% of the folks ok what's
she saying here so a few things one
immediate keep portraying her as
charismatic I'm not seeing it I'm not
she's more charismatic than Hillary
Clinton but so is whatever died in the
studio around here okay lots of things
are more charismatic than Hillary
Clinton that is not a standard for
charisma but beyond that her plan
actually makes no sense because the fact
is if she thinks she's raising two point
seven five trillion dollars over the
next ten years with this wealth tax
number one it's unconstitutional there's
nothing in the Constitution that allows
you to tax wealth not income right which
was legalized idiotically by the 16th
amendment but well there's nothing there
that allows you to tax wealth itself
especially stuff that people have
already paid tax on you're talking about
I already pay property tax I already
paid tax on all of the income that I
make and now you're gonna come in and
tax me again based on what moral
principle are you gonna tax me again
beyond that just speaking realistically
it is not going to raise this amount of
money that is not me speaking that's
factcheck.org speaking quote some
economists think that assumption is too
rosy well in the Tax Policy Center nor
the Tax Foundation have yet released a
full analysis of Warren's plan
economists at both said there is reason
to believe that Warren's revenue
estimate is too high
kyle palmer lou a chief economist and
vice president of economic analysis at
the non profit pro-business Tax
Foundation said the assumption of 15%
tax evasion her plan says there will be
15% tax evasion or avoidance he says
that's actually the average avoidance
for the entire US tax system which is
primarily the income tax and payroll tax
these taxes are much harder to avoid
than a wealth tax because an income
transaction is hard to game or hide from
the tax authorities a wealth tax on the
other hand is much harder to enforce for
one much of the wealth tax base doesn't
have a market price so for example I own
an ownership stake in Daily wire how
does that value out the answer is you
have no actual answer because there is
no way to evaluate the fair market value
it is not a publicly held company it's
not like a piece of stock that is
publicly held and it's not just people
on the right who are suggesting all of
this Lawrence Summers who was formerly a
Harvard University Dean and he was
every secretary from 1999 to 2001 an
economic adviser for Barack Obama and
Natasha sarin an assistant professor of
law University of Pennsylvania Law
School they published an op-ed in The
Washington Post just earlier this year
saying common sense revenue estimates by
economists who are not very deeply
steeped in revenue estimation tend to be
overly optimistic the two looked at US
experience with the state tax data and
concluded that Warren's wealth tax would
only raise about 40 percent of the
amount that Warren is estimating so now
2.7 five trillion like one trillion like
1.2 trillion over 10 years which doesn't
pay for any of her stuff also it causes
people not to save because the people
not to buy assets in the United States
and it causes people to flee everyone a
vast number of European countries that
have tried to wealth tax millionaires
and billionaires flood they just took
their money and they went elsewhere see
this is the nice thing about being super
wealthy you don't have to stick around
to watch Elizabeth Warren take your
money you can just move your money you
can just take your money and go to the
Cayman Islands and buy a nice home there
and stay there you don't have to worry
about Elizabeth Warren summers in serán
wrote we suspect it to a great extent it
reflects the myriad ways wealthy people
avoid paying estate taxes that in some
form will be applicable and any actually
legislated wealth tax so for example the
estate tax is a form of wealth tax right
you die and then the government open
like they walk right by your corpse they
open up your safe and they chase to take
a chunk of your money okay what people
do is instead they create living trusts
and they put their money in a living
trust for their children's when they die
the money didn't belong to them it
belongs to their children already this
avoids the estate tax
they say all of the methods that are
used to avoid the estate tax will also
be used to avoid the wealth tax they say
these include questionable appraisals
valuation discounts for illiquidity and
lack of control establishment of trusts
that enable division of assets among
family members with substantial founder
control planning devices that give some
income to charity while keeping the
remainder for the donor and
beneficiaries tax advantaged lending
schemes and other complex devices known
only to sophisticated investors except
for reducing a naive calculation by 15%
Warren's economic advisors do not seem
to take accounts of these devices if our
suspicion is correct a wealth tax will
not yield the revenue its proponents
hope for and when actual scorekeeper
score actual proposals their estimates
will disappoint advocates and this is
obviously true but Elizabeth Warren's
gonna keep trotting
that out there it doesn't matter because
again she gives a feeling of
flattery to a media that is desperate to
be flattered it's the reason the media
hate Trump so much by the way it's not
just because Trump is a Republican it's
because Trump makes them feel like they
don't get Americans try they look at
Trump and they have scorn for him they
think oh what a dummy what a fool what a
stupid guy how could he be outsmarting
us how could he have power how's this
possible Elizabeth Warren makes members
of the media feel good about themselves
even if her proposals don't actually
make any sense at all and they actually
don't make it by the way her own
proposals makes so little sense
honestly that she was rejecting a lot of
her own proposals as the latest
2003-2004 make sure talks about
universal child care for every child age
zero to five she wrote an entire book
about how this would disadvantage
married mothers who stay at home and how
you'd need now subsidies for married
moms who stay at home right she wrote an
entire in her book she talks about why
it would be a mistake to relieve student
loans to relieve student loans right she
said that it would be a mistake not to
just cap tuition right now to just cap
the amount that that colleges can charge
for tuition on a public level as opposed
to subsidizing the student loan industry
as opposed to paying off people's loans
and quote-unquote paying for free
college and all of the rest of this and
now she backs all of those things why
because here's the dirty little secret
Elizabeth Warren has become a deeply
dishonest politician I'll provide proof
of this in one second plus I'll tell you
where she actually stands in the polls
and why she really is the shadow
frontrunner at this point for the
Democrats first I don't go to the post
office anymore why well it takes a lot
of time I have to get all my stuff put
it in the car I have to go drive to the
post office I have to wait in line
there's a lot of great stuff at the post
office but do I really want to wait in
line or get in the car and do all those
things so I really want have to go to
the grocery store to buy stamps well
instead I could just sit at my computer
like I do the rest of my day in the
middle of my work and I could use stamps
calm I could use the interwebs to do the
same thing for cheaper stamps calm bring
all the amazing services of the US
postal office directly to your computer
with your small office sending invoices
and online seller shipping out products
or even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps calm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready you just handed your mail
carrier or you drop it in the mailbox it
is
indeed that simple stamps comes a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money so what exactly are you
waiting for right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitment which is a
hell of a deal just for trying go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that is stamps.com
enter Shapiro for that special deal
again while epping over the post office
and you could just do this stuff from
your desk
stamps.com enter code Shapiro okay so
where do we stand in the polls and then
we'll get to why Elizabeth Warren proof
that she is deeply dishonest ok so here
are the polls according to CBS News
brand-new poll CBS News you gov tracker
they they have now pulled all of the
Super Tuesday states all of the states
up through Super Tuesday so it goes in
the Democratic Party goes Iowa and the
New Hampshire and then South Carolina
Nevada California and a bunch of other
states on Super Tuesday right now Bernie
Bernie doesn't win very many delegates
Biden has 600 delegates available
through Super Tuesday Warren it's at
5:45 that's a disaster for Biden Biden's
entire narrative is that he's the
inevitable nominee and the inevitable
president if Warren emerges from Iowa
and New Hampshire victorious I don't
think that his lead simply holds up in a
lot of these Super Tuesday states Bernie
Sanders is rounding out the top tier of
candidates with 286 delegates in those
races but I don't think that Bernie
retains all those delegates because
remember all the polls are being done
now about all of those states but those
states are time-delayed because Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina Nevada and then
on ones that you have California Utah
Colorado Oklahoma Texas Arkansas
Tennessee Alabama North Carolina
Virginia Minnesota and Maine and Vermont
and Massachusetts which presumably
Warren will win since she's a senator
from there if Elizabeth Warren emerges
as the serious challenger from Iowa and
New Hampshire and Bernie doesn't win
either of those states I think Bernie's
toast I think at that point Bernie is
done and you can take a lot of those
delegates those 286 delegates and you
can toss them to Elizabeth Warren
according that CBS News you got pull
state-by-state and vote preference New
Hampshire now sees Warren just slightly
up over Biden and Sanders and first
choice preference there which is a
change for her remember she was
underperforming in New Hampshire as of a
couple of weeks ago they say that that's
a three-way contest but
that's not a three-way contest if
Elizabeth Warren wins Iowa and she
already is running even with Biden and
Sanders in that state then she wins that
state to a Biden holds a small edge over
Sanders in first choice preference in
Iowa Sanders has a narrow edge over
Biden in Nevada but where is Elizabeth
Warren in these states well she has the
best on-the-ground organization in Iowa
she trails substantially by 9 to 12
points in Iowa she trails Bernie by 9
she trails Biden by 12 in Iowa but the
smart money says that that is under
poling her supporters remember Iowa is a
caucus state I recall back in 2008
Hillary Clinton was expected to win Iowa
over Barack Obama and Barack Obama won
instead there were suspicions that that
may have not been entirely on the
up-and-up South Carolina
Joe Biden has a wide lead he's at 43
percent compared to Bernie at 18 and
Elizabeth Warren at 14 but again that
relies somewhat on momentum remember
that Ted Cruz won South Carolina I
believe last time around and it was
widely perceived that Ted Cruz was going
to have some sort of fire well whenever
a candidate talks about a firewall I
have yet to see it candidate with a
quote-unquote firewall where the
firewall holds right now Bernie Sanders
is up slightly in Nevada 29 to 27 over
Joe Biden but Elizabeth Warren's at 18
which means she is in striking distance
overall in the early contests it is now
Elizabeth Warren 26 Joe Biden 25 Bernie
Sanders 19 and it is likely that Bernie
Sanders is going to continue to recede
and Elizabeth Warren is going to
increase according to CBS News Biden
support has largely held an even risen
in some places like in Iowa so the
movement toward Warren is not attrition
from Biden but of lower tier candidates
losing supporter who have gone to Warren
or in lesser numbers to Sanders for
instance Warren has benefited most from
former Kamala Harris's supporter
switching their legions 29% were backing
Harris in July whom we reintroduce study
of switch to Warren Biden only picked up
15% Warren is also under consideration
by more Democrats 60% than Biden is 50%
Biden does better than Warren and being
named the first choice but she is best
among second choice candidates and again
it's really about electability and as
the polls changed for Elizabeth Warren
on that front that is very bad news for
Joe Biden meaning he has to continue
making the case that Warren can't be
Trump that's really what this is about
and in that case
by the way is extremely strong that
worin cannot be Trump it's a very strong
case
but among Democratic voters the
perception has been growing that
Elizabeth Warren would probably win
against Trump as of June only 39% of
Democratic voters considering Warren
said that they thought that she could
probably win against Trump now it is 55%
58% of Sanders supporters think he would
probably beat Trump overall most
Democrats are pretty optimistic that
somebody anybody they nominate will beat
Trump so again I think that went and
here's here's I mean as I say the self
flattering assumption by the media is
reflected in their media coverage and
that of course shapes public opinion one
of the numbers in this poll that really
says a lot is that when asked which
candidate is the most knowledgeable
it says Warren at 42% Biden in Sanders
tied at 24 and that is because when you
just keep repeating over and over and
over again that Warren has a plan
doesn't matter if the plan is crap as
far as and then there's a third question
which is whether age is a concern 66% of
Democrats say that Joe Biden is that age
is not a concern but 31% say that he's
too old 37% said that Sanders is too old
only 5% of Democrats say that Warren is
too old so more evidence of Joe Biden
stumbling and bumbling about the
campaign trail is not going to be good
for him either and 46% of Democrats say
that they would be enthusiastic about
Elizabeth Warren as the candidate
compared to 38% for Sanders and only 29%
for Joe Biden so again these are bad
numbers for Joe Biden he looks very weak
right now
among Democrats they asked which message
is more attractive to you you want a
candidate who is more progressive than
Obama or a return to the country before
Trump only only 40 percent said then we
want to return to normalcy 60 percent
say they want a more progressive
candidate then Donna then then Barack
Obama was so these are bad numbers bad
numbers for Joe Biden and Joe Biden is
weak and again I don't think that Warren
is really gonna go after Biden in a
serious way I think she's just going to
assume that Biden is going to fade into
the Brigadoon like fog and I think that
she's probably correct about that now
there's a problem which is that all of
you talk about Elizabeth Warren being
dreamily honest and non Clintonian is a
lie that's a real problem for her
because she has yet to meet serious
public scrutiny
remember the Elizabeth Warren who built
up a public profile from 2003 to 2008 is
not the same as the Elizabeth Warren now
running for president we talked about
this last week the Elizabeth Warren from
2003 to 2008 was actually a fairly
interesting progressive figure who
thought differently on school vouchers
and student loans who thought seriously
about issues like bankruptcy now she's
just a rubber stamp progressive who
sounds a lot like Bernie Sanders and
here's the proof today there's a piece
from Jonathan Allen and NBC News talking
about how Warren and Clinton are talking
behind the scenes now which it which is
Warren's worst nightmare right is that
she's perceived as as the second coming
of Hillary Clinton that that is not what
you want to be according to Jonathan
Allen Elizabeth Warren's team doesn't
want to talk about Hillary Clinton but
that doesn't mean the 2020 presidential
candidate isn't talking with her party's
2016 nominee the two women have kept a
line of communication open
since the Massachusetts senator decided
to run for president though only a
conversation around the time of Warren's
launch has been previously reported
according to several people familiar
with their discussions who spoke to NBC
on the condition of anonymity because of
the political sensitivity of private
interactions it's hard to know exactly
how many times they've reached out to
each other or precisely what they've
discussed in part because neither camp
wants to reveal much of anything about
their interaction and in part because
they have each other's phone numbers and
there are many ways for two high-powered
politicians to communicate that don't
involve their staffs one source was
aware of just one additional call
between Warren and Clinton since then
but a person close to Clinton said the
contact has been substantial enough to
merit attention describing a
conversation between the two as
seemingly recent because it was front of
mind for her that has clearly not gone
unnoticed I think she really appreciates
that the person close to Clinton said
well Warren making overtures to Clinton
is definitely different than Warren just
a few years ago I'll explain momentarily
first let's talk about what you're gonna
do with your business it's getting late
in the year now past summer and that
means you better rev up for the end of
the year as vacation season wraps up and
you fall back to your normal routine you
need to get your stuff done with
LegalZoom before we hit end of year
there is an urgency to getting your
business on track before we hit 2020
right now LegalZoom is making it easier
to
say so long to summer by saving you 10%
off the things you need to accomplish
for all you entrepreneurs that haven't
set up an LLC d/b/a or S corp for your
business now would be the time to save
money and if you've been meaning to wrap
up your last will or a living trust but
you can't seem to find the time take a
moment do the right thing for your
family make sure they're taken care of
if you get confused or have questions
don't let that slow you down either
LegalZoom isn't a law firm their network
of independent attorneys and tax
professionals can give you the advice
you need to make the right decisions
look legalism is so good that I'm a
lawyer when I have to do legal documents
and I don't feel like spending a ton on
hourly fees Legal Zoom is where I go
I've been doing this for years long
before they're an advertiser save ten
percent for a limited time on the things
you've been meaning to do with Legal
Zoom just go to Legal Zoom calm right
now
use code been at checkout LegalZoom
where life meets legal go check them out
right now Legal Zoom calm use code been
at checkout Legal Zoom is where life
meets legal so again elizabeth warren is
now reaching out to hillary clinton yeah
this is very different from Elizabeth
Warren talking about Hillary Clinton as
of her book the two income trap in 2003
hey Glen thrush wrote about Glenn
Kessler rather wrote about this for the
Washington Post just a couple of years
ago he said Warren noted that Hillary
Clinton had received a hundred and forty
thousand dollars in campaign
contributions from banking industry
executives that she sought a Senate seat
why was that relevant because she talks
about how she had met with Hillary
Clinton about a bankruptcy bill in the
early 90s and she praised Hillary
Clinton has extremely bright she should
call her quote impatient lightning-quick
interested in all the nuances and then
it turns out that Hillary voted against
the bill or in favor of the bill that
Elizabeth Warren opposed and she tore
into her in the to income trap
she said the bill was essentially the
same but Hillary Rodham Clinton was not
Hillary could not afford such a
principled position campaigns cost money
and that money wasn't coming from
families in financial trouble
here's Elizabeth Warren circa 2004
talking about how Hillary Clinton is
basically a corrupt figure she was then
first lady this is in the 1990s late
1990s mrs. Clinton saw the piece and I
got a call from the White House I go
over the law it's a complex law went
over the economics show to the graph
show to the charts and she got it she
turned around a whole
ministration on the subject of
bankruptcy she died and then one of the
first bills that came up after she was
Senator Clinton was the bankruptcy bill
her husband had vetoed it very much at
her urging and she voted in favor of it
as Senator Clinton the pressures are
very different okay so this is Warren
back when she was honest right know he
got Elizabeth Warren making phone calls
to Hillary Clinton oh they're best
friends and Elizabeth Warren has shifted
her own positions on a variety of issues
ranging from the subsidization of
college education to school choice
because the pressures of being a senator
or a presidential candidate are very
different now this does pose a problem
for the Democrats because the fact is
that most people in the country are not
on board with all of the progressive
views on all the issues David Leonhardt
has a piece in The New York Times today
talking about this okay he's on the left
and he says it's not that progressivism
can't win he's saying that there's
certain progressive issues that are
deeply unpopular and they should be and
he points out a couple of issues as an
example he says the first is the idea of
decriminalizing border crossings so that
the illegal entry into this country
would only be a civil violation
supporters of the idea says Leonhardt
make intricate technocratic arguments
about how decriminalization won't make
the border less secure but most voters
turn out they don't buy the long
explanations for why the policy doesn't
mean what it certainly seems to mean
less border enforcement in an NPR PBS
Newshour Marist Poll 67% of registered
voters call decriminalization a bad idea
hey when it comes to slavery reparations
sixty-three percent of americans call it
a bad idea when it comes to replacing
private insurance fifty five percent say
it's a bad idea when it comes to when it
comes to free public college fifty-one
percent say it's a good idea but forty
five percent say it's a bad idea in
other words there are a lot of issues
where people are generally in favor of
progressive principles until they get
the details in which place they switch
but Democrats advantage on on general
election directed questions has been
fading right David leonhardt points out
that slightly more voters say that the
idea is being offered by the Democratic
candidates would now hurt the country
more than would help the country
according to that NPR poll as
of September 2018 53% of Americans favor
the said it had a favorable view of the
Democratic Party versus 42% unfavorable
43% had a favorable view of the
Republican Party compared to 52%
unfavorable as of September 2019 fast
forward a year the two parties are now
identical 45% of Americans say that they
are favorable toward one of the parties
52% of Americans say they're unfavorable
toward one of the two parties meaning
that basically the parties are now on
even footing so all of the talk about
Elizabeth Warren this and Elizabeth
Warren that as she's skews radical it's
going to be unpopular and this is the
problem inside the Democratic primaries
what is going to create victory in a
Democratic primary may be mutually
exclusive with what creates victory for
Democrats in a general election
take for example bait or rock soap 800
work is basically John Cusack and say
anything standing outside the democratic
process holding a boombox and what that
means that he is the most
enthusiastically crude of all the
candidates he has no nuance to his ideas
he doesn't have any sort of attempt to
to rounds off the the hard edges instead
he just spits out he's sort of like
younger Bernie Sanders I mean down to
the hands and here is beta O'Rourke
talking about what he thinks the
Democratic primary voters want to hear
America is a violent racist country
that's a hell of a campaign slogan there
bado this is a violent country that
loses more than forty thousand of our
fellow Americans every year to gun
violence and this is a country that has
been defined by foundational systemic
endemic racism since the very founding
of this country August 20th of 1619 the
first time that a kidnapped African was
brought here against his will and made
to serve as a slave to build the
greatness and the success and the wealth
of this country which his descendants
would never be able to fully participate
in this is the reality of the United
States of America and sooner or later
it was going to find us okay I mean
that's a hell of a campaign slogan
America was founded in crap and now it's
still crap and it was gonna come back to
haunt us
that sounds great bado I mean dude needs
to go back to his Ivy League education
as rich parents paid for and smoke a
bong and chill because he is just he's
ridiculous I mean and then and then beta
went further he said we should legalize
10 million illegal immigrants this is a
hell of a campaign slogan right here
from Bay door open again bado thinks
that he is representing the it of the
Democratic Party he's hoping that if he
says the F word a lot
if he says that he'll somehow win the
nomination
[Music]
okay so again if this is where the
Democratic Party wants to go and
Elizabeth Warren is closer to this then
she is to Joe Biden that's a real
problem for Rahm Emanuel was the chief
of staff to Barack Obama and is
certainly no right winger he says listen
these positions are untenable you are
not going to be able to win a general
election on these bases we've taken a
position so far and the candidates have
through the process if you have not
about on basically Medicare for all
which is we're going to eliminate 150
million people's health care and we're
going to provide health care for people
that just come over the border that is
an untenable position for the general
election okay of course Rahm Emanuel is
exactly right that's coming from a guy
who is so passionate about his left-wing
agenda he used to drop dead he was
literally called dead fish Emmanuel he
would drop dead fish in the in like the
lockers of Congress people that he
didn't like in order to try to get them
to vote with him like to threaten them
when he was in Congress me that that guy
is not a softie on politics by any
measure and he's looking at the
Democratic Party going you guys are
skewing the way too far to the left and
that right there is the problem for
Elizabeth Warren now in a second we're
going to talk about the Republican case
for 2020 and again this is all about can
the president control himself can he
control himself because if he could and
he would be in pretty good shape going
for it but we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about you know
you're out at some sort of dinner part
and you're looking for a job or you're
just looking to make contacts your
rainmaking a little bit and somebody
says you have a business cards you pull
out your business card and it looks like
this ridiculous thing that you cut out
for piece of paper yourself that you
printed off your printer and just looks
like garbage well instead of that you
should be heading on over to Vistaprint
hey you can own the now with vistaprint
you can own your own life you can own
your own business future with a nice
business card really does make a
difference it really makes an impression
for just ten bucks vistaprint gives you
five hundred personalized cards with
exactly the look that you want that is a
low price to make a lasting impression
and because you can choose the colors
fonts designs images that means you can
create something as unique and
compelling as your business as if you
needed any more reasons to choose at
Vistaprint you can feel good knowing
that Vistaprint also uses only carefully
selected inks responsibly sourced to
paper stocks your satisfaction is 100%
guaranteed or your money back they will
make a racket hands in a lot of business
cards I will admit that the look of the
business card does make a difference in
to whether I hand it off to my assistant
or whether it goes in the Garbage Pail
Vistaprint wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to vistaprint and enter
promo code
Shapiro's - that's shapiro and the
number - for free shipping on all
business cards any style any quantity is
a limited time offer on the now at
Vistaprint comp promo code Shapiro -
that is promo code Shapiro followed by
the number to you support our show when
you support or sponsor so please check
out vistaprint.com and use that promo
code at Shapiro - so let them know that
we sent you well but we'll get to more
of all of this in just one second first
I'm go subscribe over a daily wired I
come when you do you get the rest of
this show live you also get the Michael
Miller show live in the end road Clavin
show live you also get to be part of
daily we're backstage we have all sorts
of goodies the real reason is because if
you spend $99 a year you get this the
very greatest in all beverage vessels
the leftist years
hot or cold tumbler it is indeed a
magnificent and really because you're
joining the team helping us bring you
the kind of content that you want every
day without the without the scrutiny and
and nastiness of left trying to do
platform everybody they don't like go
subscribe become part of the team we
really appreciate it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
well before we leave the Democrats
entirely I would be remiss if I did not
point out if I did not point out that
the most incompetent candidate on the
Democratic side of the aisle is not in
fact Joe Biden it is Komal Harris
remember that time when Kamala Harris
seemed like she was skyrocketing toward
the nomination remember there was that
first debate where she talked about
busing and she attacked Joe Biden it was
wow that was incredible and then it
turns out she's terrible at this
well she's truly terrible at this and
over the weekend she proved again that
she was terrible at this she was
campaigning and a person got up and
described Republican voters and Trump
voters as quote mentally and
Kamala Harris heard this and laughed
okay this is not a question as to
whether she heard this she obviously
heard this she responded directly to the
comment here is the original clip so I
don't buy that argument that impeachment
does not make sense and it will not quit
I don't buy that argument there needs to
be accountability I mean what are you
gonna do in the next one year to
diminish the mentally to action
of this well said guys well said what do
you do to planning to diminish the
mentally fashion of this
country the guy says and she says well
said well I mean she is in favor of
eugenic abortions that would be one
thing presumably that should be in favor
of because she's a terrible person who
believes terrible things but I mean that
the term mentally I'm old
enough to remember when that was
considered a really really bad thing
because it is a bad thing mocking people
who have a mental disability is a
ridiculous ridiculous thing now here's
the funny part
right Oh Kamala Harris is asked about
this and then she's like why did I never
heard it you literally responded to the
guy you literally responded to that
human being okay because that like come
on come on who you gonna believe Kamala
Harris or your own eyes and ears here's
Kamala Harris now apologizing for this
it's offensive and you would think that
in the year 2019
people would have a much better
understanding of how hurtful a term like
that can be but also the history behind
it which is a history of of really
ignoring the needs and the realities and
the capacity of our disability community
so we didn't correct him though did you
hear him I heard him talk about the
other stuff and then that came later and
it was not something that I really heard
or processed or you know or in any way
condone oh really really is that what
happened right there look in my family
we actually take this issue fairly
seriously my grandfather used to work
with Easter Seals which is a group that
works at people who had mental
disabilities my mom when she first
started out did special education for
kids like it's a pretty it's a pretty
serious issue
qumola harris pretending that she didn't
hear the end of that remember when
Donald Trump does that sort of stuff
it's the end of the world right when you
have somebody who says something bad
about illegal immigrants and then he
says well I guess you can do that
influence Eze you know I guess he can do
that in Florida get away with that in
the Panhandle and everything oh that was
really bad cuz it was bad and then
Kamala Harris responds directly to a
person who calls a vast swath of the
voting public mentally and
she's like well I didn't hear that part
you know the party said directly to me
so how do the media cover this if this
doesn't tell you everything you need to
know about the about the way the media
covered this NBC News's headline you
ready senator Harris apologizes for
appearing to laugh in response to man
who described president Trump's actions
as mentally appearing to laugh
appearing like appeared she laughed we
saw it we heard it appeared it's all
good it's all good guys well done media
okay now to the Republican side of the
aisle now the fact is that Democratic
radicalism should be an opportunity for
President Trump as I have been saying
for years on end all President Trump has
to do is be quiet that's all he has to
do because it turns out that reality has
a fairly conservative bent on issues
like illegal immigration you know saying
that we should keep track of the people
who are in the country that we should
make sure that we know who is entering
the country this seems like it makes a
certain amount of root sense especially
when you get stories like this one
out of Montgomery County according to
Dan Moore's Montgomery County's top
elected official Marc Elrich stood
before a bank of TV cameras this summer
to praise the county's diversity and
promise the most limited of cooperation
with federal immigration agents I'd say
we've learned how to manage immigration
pretty well he said without a lot of
drama and nonsense since then there's
been plenty of both at least according
to the opposing sides of a roiling
political debate centered on the
left-leaning
Maryland jurisdiction national attention
has fallen on Montgomery in large part
because over the five-week stretch since
the county executives pronouncement
seven undocumented immigrants living in
the county were arrested on sex assault
charges two were accused of raping the
same 11-year old girls according to the
Washington Post another reportedly tried
to kill his victim by choking her in a
hallway of her apartment building by
Friday afternoon Ken Cuccinelli acting
director of ice tweeted a debate
challenge to Elle rich over the merits
of what Cuccinelli described as the
county's sanctuary protection policies
for undocumented immigrants cuccinelli
wrote quote I'll defended children and
crime victims ell rich can defend
rapists and murderers who shouldn't even
be in this country oryx then shot back
it's a stunt I might to bait him if he'd
agree with the statement that Montgomery
County is not a sanctuary City and that
Montgomery County is not protecting
criminals the guys in jail would
probably not feel very protected yeah
except that when you don't cooperate
with the federal government on
immigration sometimes you're not keeping
track of how legal immigrants who go on
to commit crimes hey these are all
issues where Republicans should have an
advantage instead we got a week of
controversy over whether President Trump
used a sharpie on a map now on the
issues again even the left
David Leonhardt is saying on illegal
immigration on racial reparations on
getting rid of private health care
insurance the Democrats are way out of
tune shouldn't Trump just be hammering
that over and over instead we got a week
of controversy over whether the National
Oceanographic and Atmospheric
Administration was actually right or
wrong in their assessment of a threat
level of a hurricane hitting Alabama a
week of this a week of this and the news
continues to break that the NOAA
basically acted in order to avoid
damaging president Trump's fragile ego
this is a waste of time it's a waste of
energy and the fact that people on
Twitter keep defending it demonstrates
that they don't understand that Twitter
is not real life and winning the footer'
battle does not mean winning an election
hey Andrew Friedman Kobe it quits and
Jason salmon out I love that the
Washington Post put three reporters on
this NOAA staff warned in September
first directed against contradicting
Trump nearly a week before the NOAA
publicly backed President Trump over its
own scientists atop NOAA official warned
its staff against contradicting the
president in an agency-wide directive
sent September first to National Weather
Service personnel hours after Trump
asserted with no evidence that Alabama
would most likely be hit much harder
than anticipated staff was told to only
stick with official National Hurricane
Center forecast if questions arise on
some national level social media posts
which hit the news this afternoon they
were also told not to provide any
opinion according to a copy of the email
obtained by the Washington Post in NOAA
a meteor meteorologist who spoke on
condition of anonymity for fear of
retribution said the note was understood
initially to be referring to Trump and
came after the National Weather Service
office in Birmingham contradicted Trump
by tweeting that Alabama would not see
any impacts from the hurricane so the
NOAA sent a note saying let's just stick
with the National Hurricane Center
forecast and we won't and we won't you
know contradict
Trump any attempt to shield Trump's ego
honestly I don't see the purpose of it I
really don't the fact is the President
Trump for all the talk about him being
thin-skinned do takes more crap than any
other politician I've ever seen in my
life
and guess what he's still there he
hasn't gone anywhere has he and yet this
attempt to sort of shield him it ends up
creating worse headlines than if you
just let Trump own it if Trump just went
okay screw that one up you know I guess
I was out of the loop the Democrats
would still attack him but they wouldn't
have any place to go because most people
would be like what are they attacking
him over is just the screw up who cares
who cares meanwhile it is amusing to
watch as other Republicans seem to
believe that they can jump in against
President Trump in this race it's a mark
Sanford the former Republican governor
of South Carolina remember remember that
time when he was governor of South
Carolina and then he went traveling the
Appalachian Trail
that was his euphemism for sleeping with
his mistress in South America and then
he had to resign and then he ran for
Congress again when now he's back and he
wants to run for president and he was
expecting these strange new respect of
the media it is incredible to watch
Republicans expect strange new respect
and they really believe that the media
going to treat them with kid gloves
because after all many in the media I
hate President Trump that means that if
someone runs against Trump they should
like them and that's not how this works
that's not how this works
you're not going to receive the syringe
and respect of the media for running
against Trump the fact is many in the
media would like to link every
Republican with President Trump as
Democrats are attempting to do in Texas
where Trump is less popular than the
Republican Party overall also mark
Sanford like why is he running chris
wallace basically asked him this
question in Sanford's didn't have a
great answer the mistakes in life the
mistakes that we make her the great
tuitions of life they cost us but you
can learn from them and for me I learned
a level of humility a level of empathy
that I didn't have before a level of
judgment it is something of great regret
it's something I've apologized
extensively for and in contrast to the
president where he says there's not a
single thing that he sort of regrets or
apologized for i profoundly apologize
for that okay that that's always a great
campaign slogan i profoundly apologize
for that sanford 20/20 good luck with
all of that now again I don't think the
Trump is gonna be substantially
challenged from inside the party I know
that Matt Drudge is headlining with
Sanford having another challenger like
Joe Walsh and Mark Sanford are gonna do
any damage to Trump that obviously is
not going to be a thing the real damage
to Trump in the end is not gonna come
from somebody outside Trump it's gonna
come from Trump himself and a good
example of this happened over the
weekend so President Trump was
apparently planning to negotiate with
the Taliban this has been going on for a
while and a lot of people I know in the
military and in the foreign policy sort
of hallways of power we're very
skeptical of this as well they should be
the Taliban is a terrorist group
that's how event is a terrorist
supporting group that is why we went
into Afghanistan in the first place
after 9/11 the united states under
george w bush offered the taliban an
opportunity to turn over to turn over
Osama bin Laden they refused Afghanistan
then was put on our bleep list and then
we invaded and well now Donald Trump is
trying to negotiate directly with the
Taliban now Barack Obama tried to do the
same thing and I criticized him for it
because you're literally negotiating
with some of the worst people on earth
to accomplish what the return to power
of the Taliban I think that that's a
great idea well Donald Trump was
apparently secretly negotiating with the
Taliban and they were even gonna get
together at Camp David the week of 9/11
which is just I mean what those optics
are just awful right Chris Wallace
pointing to the said he said
why are we inviting the Taliban to the
United States on 9/11 how is this a good
idea we don't think that back home in
the region they would take advantage of
the fact that they were at Camp David on
the 18th anniversary of 9/11 we're
kidding ourselves enormous psychological
that was going to be true whether or not
they had you know killed this one US
soldier or not that's why I questioned
the whole idea of holding the meeting he
talks about well this deal would bring
peace but it wasn't going to bring peace
I mean as we know the outlines of it
there was no national ceasefire there
was no assurance that there was going to
be a deal between the the Afghan
government and the Taliban there was no
guarantee that they were going to
protect women I mean the deal is we
sought the tentative deal in principle
did that make sense and the answer is
the tentative deal in principle did not
make any sense president Trump blew it
up over the weekend now again blowing up
a bad deal is not a bad thing announcing
secret negotiations and blowing them up
at the same time is not particularly
smart foreign policy Trump tweeted out
unbeknownst to almost everyone
the major Taliban leaders and separately
the President of Afghanistan were going
to secretly meet with me at Camp David
on Sunday nothing says secret meeting
quite like blowing it up on Twitter said
they were coming to the United States
tonight unfortunately in order to build
false leverage they admitted to an
attack in Kabul that killed one of our
great great soldiers and 11 other people
I immediately canceled the meeting and
called off peace negotiations what kind
of people would kill so many in order to
seemingly strengthen their bargaining
position they didn't they only made it
worse if they cannot agree to a
ceasefire during these very important
peace talks and would even kill 12
innocent people and they probably don't
have the power to negotiate a meaningful
agreement anyway how many more decades
are they willing to fight well I mean
the answer is you're negotiating with
them right so a lot also what kind of
people would kill an American soldier
what kind of people would shield
al-qaeda what are we what are you
talking about what are you talking about
you're literally talking why are the
Taliban such bad people I have an idea
like right here in the back I have an
idea the Taliban being bad people is
this like a great shot I can't believe
that the Taliban betrayed the principle
is varn to go really really according to
the New York Times on the Friday before
Labor Day president from gathered top
advisors in the Situation Room to
consider what could be among the
profound decisions of his presidency a
peace plan with the Taliban after 18
of grinding bloody war in Afghanistan
the meeting brought to a head a
bristling conflict conflict dividing his
foreign-policy team for months pitting
at Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
against John bolts in the National
Security Adviser
as they discussed the terms of the
agreement Pompeo and his negotiator made
the case that it would enable trump to
begin withdrawing troops while securing
a commitment from the Taliban not to
shelter terrorists Bolton argued that
Trump should keep his campaign pledge to
draw upon forces draw down forces
without getting in bed with killers
swapped in American blood trump made no
decision on the spot at some point
during the meeting the idea was floated
to finalize the negotiations in
Washington a prospect that appealed to
the president's penchant for dramatic
spectacle Trump suggested he would even
invite President Ashraf Ghani of
Afghanistan whose government had not
been party to the talks and get him to
sign on and then he wanted to bring the
Taliban to Camp David the crown jewel of
the American presidency all of this was
bad ideas bad ideas because it was all
about spectacle and not about content as
I say the president's worst enemy in
2020 is as always the president because
he's done well on a lot of fronts he's
done well when it comes to judges he's
done well when it comes to the economy
he's done well when it's come to
regulations but his instinct for the
dramatic is a real negative for him and
it could hurt him badly come 2020 okay
time for some things I like and then
things I hate so things that I like so
if you're interested in a lot of the
stories that been coming out about AI
and it's about the the nature of the
human brain and the possibility of
networking in with other brains there
was a story this week about this about
how it could change human existence as
we know it you could read each other's
thoughts in a creek could create Network
thinking and all of us it may raise some
serious questions about free will and
the soul and this brings to mind a book
that I recently read by JP Moreland
who's a philosophy professor / Biola
University and it's called the soul how
we know it's real and why it matters now
this is kind of a fascinating
conversation because obviously if you're
a materialist you believe that the brain
is all there is there is no such thing
as a soul mental phenomena are basically
just what what they have what they have
termed to be you know outgrowth of just
mental activity they're they're kind of
false positives that effectively your
mental activity your feeling of
conscious
is not real it's just a brain firing
she's neurons firing
there's nothing separate you don't have
free will you can't make your own
decisions I think this is a really
interesting and important debate and as
part of the debate you should check out
JP Moreland's book the soul because the
fact is if we don't have free will that
has some pretty significant
ramifications for our politics and for
our decision-making if we don't have the
capacity to think freely if biology is
all there is and there's no afterlife
that changes the math of it all of these
are interesting and fascinating debates
that lie at the root of Western
civilization as I talked about in my own
book the right side of history this book
is is well worth reading JP Moreland
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so now we're in the game of playing
according to the media we are going to
play who took a picture with whom now
it's funny we didn't play this for years
when there were pictures of Barack Obama
Lewis Farrakhan and it was like oh you
know he's using a vent man like why are
you making a big deal out of Barack
Obama with Louis Farrakhan and he's just
Bill Ayers was just some guy from the
neighborhood you know did Barack Obama
and Jeremiah Wright you know we went to
his church but did he really mean it
sure he titled the second book after a
speech from Jeremiah Wright but did that
really mean anything well now we're in
the business of you took a picture with
a guy once that means that you and he
are an absolute codes I've experienced
this myself right I was in a picture
with Steve King because I went I spoke
at a congressional breakfast in
Washington DC this would've been two
three years ago before Steve King's big
blow about white nationalism and so
every time Steve King is in the news
people throw that picture out there as
though there aren't pictures of me with
literally dozens of Congress people
including with some Democrats right you
know that but apparently that's the way
this now works is that if they can catch
you in a picture with somebody very bad
they did this to Jordan Peterson also
Jordan Peterson was in a picture with a
guy who's wearing a shirt about
Islamophobia that was a silly shirt and
Jordan got in trouble because the guy
wore a shirt okay now this is the way
that this is gonna be played so now
they're doing this with Lindsey Graham
so Lindsey Graham according to the
Washington Post appeared in a photo with
Girt Wilders a controversial Dutch
parliamentary leader with anti Islam and
anti-immigrant views while both attended
a European security conference in Italy
how they were in a picture together
that's unbelievable I mean that must
mean you know they're pictures of me
with people on the left that must mean
that I'm on the Left obviously there's a
picture of me standing next to Larry
Wilmore we must agree on everything and
that's the way this works now now there
are pictures with me with all sorts of
people
tens of thousands of people in fact
presumably I agree with all of them on
everything and it's very bad that we
were in a picture together now there are
certain people who are so obviously evil
you don't want to be in a picture with
that right somebody is wearing a Nazi
uniform you're not gonna be in a picture
with them but do I know that Lindsey
Graham knows everything about Kurt Vile
doors or was he just some guy who he had
sort of a baseline level of knowledge
about but not enough to say I'm never
taking a picture with that guy it is a
really really stupid game and when play
stupid games win stupid prizes that that
is the way that the modern media
currently works ok we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content welcome to
the week there's going to be a big
Democratic debate later this week we're
gonna be building up in prep for it so
exciting we'll see you here a little bit
later or we'll see you here tomorrow I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation